[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
première étape dans l'aménagement de la
rente entre Saint-Malo et Dinard là où
la marée fait pénétrer et redescendre
180 millions de mètres cubes d'eau de
mer l'estuaire de la Rance vient d'être
fermée par le barrage provisoire à
l'abri duquel cédera la première usine
marée motrice
des 6 Pertuis de régularisation sur la
rive droite à l'écluse sur la rive
gauche la ligne des gabions est
maintenant continue derrière la rince
est devenue un lac
les ouvriers viennent d'achever la
consolidation des derniers gabions qui
ont bouclé l'estuaire ces cylindres
creux aux parois métalliques qu'on a
enfonce dans l'eau et dont on assure
ensuite la stabilité en hiver ça un
mélange de sable et d'eau l'eau
s'échappe le sable reste
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la phase la plus délicate des
travaux qui est maintenant achevée et il
appartient au plongeur de vérifier
l'étanchéité de l'édifice
sur la rive gauche les deux ponts
mobiles en position levée sont déjà en
place il permettront d'assurer la
liaison routière d'une rive à l'autre en
faisant franchir l'écluse aménagé pour
la navigation une écluse de 13 mètres de
large sur 65 de noms
il reste à construire un deuxième
barrage provisoire derrière le premier
assécher entre les deux barrages pour
enfin édifier à pied sec l'usine au 24
turbines grâce auxquelles les marées
pourront produire 560 millions de
kilowatts heure il faudra encore
attendre 1966 pour voir la fin de ce
nouveau travail d'Hercule le premier du
genre dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis le Cercle militaire dont il ne
reste que quelques arches jusqu'au
quartier les plus extrêmes scopied est
aujourd'hui qu'un tas de ruines
maintenant que tout espoir d'arracher
encore une vie au décombres a disparu on
peut mieux établir le bilan de cette
catastrophe qui dépasse en ampleur la
plupart de celles qui ont endeuillé ces
derniers 20 ans
les deuils à scope et se comptent par
centaines pour un survivant sauvé qu'on
vient de cadavres restent encore sous
les normes pierres tombales que
constitue aujourd'hui les ruines de la
cité que de malheurs sur les visages de
ceux qui peuvent pleurer de joie comme
sur ceux qui ne peuvent plus pleurer à
force de désespoir
[Musique]
scopie et maintenant tu ne tombes 1500
morts les cercueils ont manqué il a
fallu creuser de longues fosses communes
où les victimes ont été ensevelies côte
à côte l'armée est arrivée est
maintenant que plus une plainte plus un
son de voix humaine ne sort des maisons
effondrées on a commencé le déblème
pendant que les bulldozers repoussent
les gravats le problème des hommes se
pose avec une acuité grandissante il y a
150.000 100 abris qui manquent de tout
de vivre dos de vêtements de couverture
on les voit autour de la ville dans les
parcs le long des routes installé dans
les débris de ce qui fut leur vie
attendre heure par heure jour par jour
une amélioration de leur terrible destin
car à ces 150 000 personnes il ne reste
rien et c'est peut-être le tableau le
plus déchirant de scopie et qui n'en
manque pas pourtant que la nuit qui
tombe sur ses groupes encore effarés
d'horreur et qui se refusent à recouvrir
totalement tous ses deuils toute cette
misère et jusqu'au silence ceux qui
n'ont plus rien que leur courage et leur
désespoir
[Musique]
exemple de la révolution qui doit
s'accomplir dans l'agriculture française
nous est donnée dans la Genèse ici comme
un beaucoup d'endroits le morcellement
abusif andait non rentable 85 % des
exploitations parce que trop exigus mais
ici à l'exemple des grandes propriétés
les agriculteurs ont réussi à créer en
des exploitations modernes qui peuvent
produire en grande quantité des qualités
valables pour l'exportation à l'échelle
de ce regroupement les vergers de la
Genèse sont devenus un exemple
l'entretien les traitements peuvent
s'opérer par moyen massifs le chef
d’exploitation peut avoir à sa
disposition les mêmes facilités qu'un
chef d'entreprise dans ses ateliers
l'interphone à sa place dans les vergers
comme à l'usine
[Musique]
à cette échelle aussi l'association a pu
créer son propre centre météorologique
avec ballon sonde et radar qui
permettent d'aménager les traitements en
fonction de l'évolution du temps
qu'un orage soit détecté un système
d'information rapide donne l'alerte aux
exploitations menacées qui peuvent
engager atteint la lutte contre les
nuées menaçants
la fusée par agrel ira jusqu'à 3000
mètres inséminé le nuage et le dissoudre
sans danger pour la récolte
de même le groupement a pu se doter
d'une organisation de sélection et
d'impactage qui va trier les fruits et
préparer l'envoi de produits
parfaitement calibrés et non moins
parfaitement présenté
un service particulier créé par le
groupement reste en liaison avec les
divers marchés et établit
quotidiennement les cours en fonction
des informations qu'il en recueillent
ainsi armé pour lutter victorieusement
contre la concurrence le groupement sert
par wagon entier les clients aussi bien
à Londres ou à Bruxelles qu'à Paris
[Musique]
tout bien entendu ne part pas vers les
grosses agglomérations pour les produits
de moindre qualité les pionniers de
l'exploitation agricole ont trouvé une
formule le surplus se vend directement
sur les marchés de la région du
producteur ou consommateur voici donc un
essai concluant de l'organisation
agricole de demain en regard que
reste-t-il au solitaire inorganisés avec
le seul espoir du client de passage
[Musique]
cet hiver plus de cheveux crépus plus de
boucles la coiffure se met aux cheveux
lisses c'est la saison dira-t-on sans
sourire de la simplicité
et voici comment Madeleine place voit la
Parisienne de cet hiver
[Musique]
voici de son côté comment l'interprète
Thérèse Chardin dont le style nous
rappelle avec tout de même un petit goût
de twist l'impératrice Eugénie
cette tête sans boucle et sans vague
peut d'ailleurs fort bien s'accommoder
d'une perruque
chez Jacques de singes cette jolie tête
ronde qui rappelle la classique coiffure
à la Jeanne d'Arc se sommes Rav
volontiers d'un chignon Berlingo
[Musique]
et nous revenons alors à la
sophistication des grandes soirées
comme aussi chez leur cas dans les
larges bandeau accuseront le romantisme
d'un visa la collection divergent et
votre coiffeur madame
[Musique]
muse ou backpack c'est toujours le même
instrument familier surtout au berger
des montagnes biniou simple on le trouve
dans toutes les traditions bretonnes on
le trouve aussi simple avec son unique
cornet mais plus grave en Bulgarie en
Grèce dans les abruptes
on le trouve plus perfectionné avec
trois ou quatre chalumeaux dans les pays
celtiques Bretagne Irlande Écosse petit
orgue primitif qui garde dans ses
sonorités nasillardes le goût des Landes
à Fougères et des longues solitudes
ainsi la cornemuse peut s'enorgueillir
d'une très haute et très universelle
tradition mais c'est seulement depuis la
fin de la guerre que la cornemuse qui
commençait à se laisser oublier a vu
renaître son succès si les sonneurs de
Bretagne se chiffraient en 1943 à
quelques douzaines ils sont aujourd'hui
plus de 2000 de là ce rendez-vous de
Brest où l'on a vu quelques 3000
sonneurs de toutes nationalités remplir
la rue de Siam d'un écho qu'elle
n'oubliera pas de sitôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]